well let's find out more about these new
measures that the chancellor is going to
unveil to tackle the cost of living
crisis spending billions to help
households across the country deal with
soaring costs and after months of
pressure from the opposition parties
rishi tonight is expected to announce
this winterfell tax on energy companies
and use that money to help bring down
people's bills well let's take a look at
how those energy costs have grown the
price cap which sets a limit on how much
energy companies can charge the average
customer for gas and electricity last
winter was 1277
pounds
following a spike in wholesale oil and
gas costs this rose to
1971 pounds in april an increase of 54
those on the prepayment meters though
pay even more and in october bills are
expected to rise again by over 800
pounds with the price cap rising to
around 2
800 pounds
our economics and data editor ed conway
is here all massive sums ed but just put
them in some kind of context for us how
bad is it historically how high is it
shall i i'll show you that first of all
because i mean you're talking about the
last few years but actually if you go
back even further and let me just take
those those energy bills in particular
because look at this going back even
further so we're looking back to 2009
and just looking at those average uh
levels of bills that we've seen going
back all that period we'll have a look
at this you know it's never been up at
the level we're at the moment so that's
kind of where we are right now that's uh
that line there but just look at where
it's heading in the next few months so
that's on the basis of if of gem is
right that we're going up to 2 800
pounds for the average household and
bear in mind what i'm showing you here
is average households you know your
experience may be very different
indeed
that shows you just the overall level
but when you kind of look at the scale
of this as a percentage of people's
average spending so you're looking at
the percentage of your average spending
which goes on these energy bills
this goes all the way back here to 1957
so we're going back basically as far as
we possibly can
and for all of that period the
proportion of average spending that's
gone on energy bills has been within
this kind of this blue this light blue
area but just look at what happens now
so here's where we are at the moment
highest since the mid 1980s so very high
in recent history but not necessarily
kind of historic highs but just look at
what happens if it does indeed go up to
2800 which is what everyone basically
expects now it is up there now that is
way above you know where we've ever seen
this before and that's basically you
know the epicenter of what the
government is so concerned about they
have already so richie sunek has already
done that that set of measures council
tax a temporary decrease in bills that
brings it down temporarily at least to
there still historically high and so the
expectation is
and that you know none of this is new
really but we're expecting the
government to
give a bit more money which basically
pushes that down a little bit so you may
be within the kind of not no longer
unprecedented area but you're still
talking about bills very very high and
by my reckoning it's kind of maybe
around there so up around
the top of that box rather than just
above it
but i mean you were mentioning jane a
second ago just what's happening with uh
those energy companies and how much
they're earning at the moment and if you
just look take a bit of context look
back last year so this is shell here uh
that's bp that's this time last year so
so q1 of uh 2021. uh you're talking
about kind of three billion dollars two
billion dollars this is kind of a
justice profit just look at what happens
to those bars this year
and it's an extraordinary increase isn't
it i mean it goes up to it is absolutely
massive and you know this is the
question as to you know how much of that
is excess profits and the big question
is going to be what's the chancellor
going to do about it
how much is it going to take off but
we're hearing from ian king a moment ago
you know you can't really make enough of
an even even a kind of relatively big
windfall tax
to generate enough money to to make
those previous charts look palatable at
all so you're still having to look back
to kind of existing taxation but even so
that's going to be the contrast looking
at what the oil giants are earning at
right now and then working out how you
take that money and bring it back to
to customers or in detail to households
and the final thing to say to you i'm
going to come and sit down final thing
to say
is you know how much of this
is temporary and that's really the big
question that we don't really know about
from uh well no one really knows that
but
you get the impression that lots of the
measures that the government is
introducing are kind of one-off so it's
just to help people get through the next
year because that's frankly the cheapest
way of doing furlough like
like
that exactly there's a desperation not
to kind of make these permanent things
but here's the thing you know a lot of
these increases in energy bills could
last a lot longer than the next year so
if you're talking about a permanent
adjustment how much people are paying
which we may be seeing because you know
we no longer have cheap russian gas
anymore then
that this may not necessarily be enough
and it's only the latest in a whole
series of measures we have to get from
the government but let's see we'll see
what they introduce and see how it's
structured it's quite a gloomy thought
but so you're essentially saying that
this big rise that we are expecting in
the autumn could potentially not be the
last or could could be
the sort of figure that we end up paying
for quite a long time well no one really
knows if you look at futures curves so
you know basically this is all measured
on the basis of what these energy
companies are paying not just this month
but in the next six months and further
ahead you've got kind of futures markets
where they can buy these energy costs uh
the wholesale energy and if you look at
them it goes up very high that's kind of
where we are at the moment and then
starts to kind of come down a bit but
even by the end of that futures curve so
looking out the next year year after
that you're still talking about levels
that are kind of pretty much double what
we're used to you know that first shot i
showed you the level we just don't seem
to be in that world anymore and if we're
not
what we're going to hear from from the
chancellor is that going to be enough it
doesn't look like it but let's let's see
see indeed edward thanks very much